hey buddy you guys hear me you hear me
okay
my name is Chad Abu Murad I hosted and
produced a show called radio lab and I'm
gonna be moderating our panel today all
creatures great and smart thanks for
coming so we have got some great
creatures for you we're gonna tell you
some amazing things
bye-bye creatures I mean scientists but
I thought I'd set it up this way before
we call everybody out
so take the situation right here we are
several hundred creatures human beings
sitting in a room and presumably we're
all here because we love animals we want
to know more about them but I would
guess that most of us deep in our hearts
believe that that we're special we were
special there's something about us that
that makes us somehow different from the
rest of the animal kingdom
and there's any number of ways that you
can try and define that people have you
know throughout history is it language
the fact that here I am speaking words
putting the words into sentences sending
it out to you guys maybe you're talking
amongst yourselves
we're all using these words very
powerful is it that or is it the fact
that we form these miraculous social
groups and we can get into an auditorium
and sit several hundred of us
side-by-side very densely packed and not
kill each other is it that the fact that
we share the fact that we can you know
accommodate one another
maybe it's the the fact that we we
showed tremendous empathy toward each
other
like for instance I went to a movie last
night and and I cried because somebody
on screen who I didn't even know was
doing something but I I had an empathic
experience so is it that or at the very
least we have these giant branes so
perhaps it's the size of our brains so
these are the questions I want to sort
of let float in the air as our panelists
come out think about language think
about sharing think about our giant
brains the fact that we're not killing
each other right now as evidence of our
specialness and I want to test these
propositions on some of these panelists
so let's bring him out Brian hare Brian
is a professor of an evolutionary
anthropology at Duke University he is an
expert on dogs all things dogs many
things chimps let's also have Vanessa
woods a researcher at Duke University as
well she has a new book out called
bonobos is it Bona bar bonobo I mess it
up bonobos handshake
it's called Jeremy Niven Jeremy is ready
for this an insect neuroscientist Klaus
Zoomer Bueller the psychologist at the
University of st. Andrews Scotland he
studies primate cognition in the wild
and Patrick HOF neurosciences at Mount
Sinai School of Medicine and now no
little surprise for our sixth seventh
eighth and ninth panelists let me bring
out Bella
and Molly as well and Tammy
we have Sammy and we also have Georgie
this is just a tease because there will
be there will actually be creatures at
this at this panel devoted to creatures
here they are they will join us at the
end of the panel and they will do
amazing things I'm just going to leave
it at that for the moment
all right so welcome everybody so so
Brian why don't we just jump in with you
we just had some dogs here I mean the
phrase sometimes I said it's a
dog-eat-dog world out there sometimes
people say that about us but I think
let's just use it to mean that animals
kill each other there's competition
there's that whole Darwinian idea of
selfishness survival of the fittest is
there any evidence in the animal kingdom
bit perhaps we've got it all wrong so
certainly one of the big ideas that
people are excited about when trying to
explain what makes humans different from
other species is that there's something
about how we cooperate it's very
different and one of the things that
stands out is that we're incredibly
altruistic so we're willing to help
somebody at a cost to ourselves and all
of us have done this before we're at
great cost to yourself you've done
something for somebody else and this is
something that scientists are pretty
some Sciences are pretty convinced that
this is really different about our
species that that nature is really red
in tooth and claw so you know as an
example many of you have probably
donated blood which helps somebody
you'll never meet many of you have
probably donated to charity and as a
thank you to the staff here even
organizing an event like this is
incredibly altruistic it takes a lot of
effort and so thank you to the staff for
working so hard to make this all happen
a real pleasure to be here and share
some a little bit about our science so
given that this is something that so
obviously seems to be human
people have been excited to look at
animal behavior one of the things that
animals do is many of them live in
groups and particularly our closest
relatives so if you think of primates
and in particularly if you think about
our closest relatives chimpanzees they
live in groups and many times they eat
together and some scientists who study
them in a wild have argued that actually
they're sharing and that they're sharing
in altruistic ways so on the on the
flipside some people have argued no no
no it's not that they're sharing
voluntarily they're actually being
forced to share that they're being
harassed by their fellow group mates and
they don't want to share they just have
to share because the other guy just
won't go away so so I'm sure you might
have experienced that also in your lives
right I mean people people sometimes
argue that about us that the only reason
that we share ever is because we're
gonna get something in return exactly so
what we wanted to do is test this idea
we wanted to challenge the notion that
it's only humans that are unique and
just find out if one of our closest
relatives is capable of voluntarily
sharing so if we can roll the video I'll
explain an experiment we did in Africa
at an orphanage to look at this so the
question we have is do our closest
relatives voluntarily share this is my
students who's equipped winda she's the
first Congolese student ever to study
but of our primate psychology in Congo
she's gonna place food in a test room
it's our test room that has two adjacent
rooms and in one of them you see there's
a bonobo and behind that room there is a
key that's locking that individual into
that room she's gonna place the food
into the center room and then we're
gonna let another individual into the
room and that individual has a choice it
can eat all of the food or it can open a
one-way key that will let its neighbor
into the room now the neighbor is
actually somebody they've never met
before it's a stranger so there's really
no reason to do that so the question is
will they share or will they be a little
selfish pigs
so it looks like they're gonna be
selfish pigs but wait this is completely
spontaneous we don't train them anything
we just taught them that they can open
that door and what you see is this
individual opens the door and shares the
food with its neighbor so what we can
conclude from this is actually in an
experimental setting it's fun if you're
a primate to voluntarily share way to
saying ways like but why if you're if
you're if you're one of these primates
who has all the food why would you share
I mean you've got all the food it's true
then it would have half of the food so
why would you share well luckily we have
an entire panel that is looking at the Y
question and we have other people on the
panel who study empathy and that maybe
part of it is that they just have a
feeling that they feel bad for the other
individual who doesn't have food it
could be a political strategy it could
be that these guys are little
politicians and they're saying you know
what I don't know you but you might
share with me later or it could be
they're selfish so they say you know
what I just want to go on a blind date
yeah so so we're working to try to
figure out why it is that they're
sharing but what we know is that they
voluntarily will donate things to
someone else now speaking of sharing and
blind dates and empathy Vanessa I'm
seeing that you also work at Duke
University do you guys know each other
we're married it was not a blind date
and sometimes he shares his food with me
although that was dessert you didn't
give me I pretended to Hall of New York
right now that you know he studies
sharing and you know of course is living
I just said we're not unique for that no
no tell me about your work you work with
a creature that is is or is not a chimp
is a bonobo technically a chimp or yes
there
species of chimpanzees but not many
people know anything about them so just
hands up who's ever heard of a bonobo
here oh my god you a New York knows
bonobo state representative oh that's
right but I I don't need to then explain
really very much about them but they
share 98.7 percent of our DNA and I
think a lot of the reason for the
confusion is that firstly they look a
lot like chimpanzees but I want you all
to see what you obviously can but see if
you can pick out the difference so let's
just roll the video
champ so you see some of them have quite
pale faces and these are bonobos and
bonobos I'm not sure if you can see it
very well but they tend to have pink
lips just like us so they have they
don't have the pigment in them oh there
they are
and that's the vocalization it sounds so
weird indeed
now where is this again this I think is
it Jacksonville Zoo in Florida I'm just
getting from the palm tree I really
don't know this isn't this is this video
that I took so and evolutionarily I mean
how would you compare it Jim to the
bonobos well I think the most important
thing the most important difference
between chimpanzees and bonobos is not
so much the physical aspect but really
what's going on inside their heads and I
guess since you know this panel is all
creatures great and smart we tend to
think of intelligence as a linear scale
with humans at the pinnacle but you know
and my other panelists are going to
really sort of demystify this and the
smartest thing about bonobos and to me
they're one of the most intelligent
animals of all is that they live in a
society with very little violence unlike
you know humans and also our other
closest living relative chimpanzees they
don't have war they don't torture and
kill each other so they don't murder and
something I think is really important is
that they're much nicer to their females
so and the females are in charge which
you know I think better
so there's very little so what happens
in bonobo society is that the female
stick together and so they don't let the
males beat them up and once there was
this alpha male alpha female called
Minnie who works at the sanctuary that
I'll show you in a minute but she was
she was just sitting there eating one
day and Tatanka who was a big sort of
Alpha bonobo he came up and he had this
kind of like big chimpanzee ID that here
was gonna behave like a male chimpanzee
and just came up with just completely
backhanded her across the face no reason
and she it was so hard it gave him
whiplash like she just kind of like
flicked her head aside and when she came
back and looked at him within about two
seconds
six five unrelated females they weren't
related they you know they just lived in
the group so they came and they chased
him all the way they're not building it
all the way under the forest so I guess
you know this kind of behavior in
bonobos is just their message to say
that one one male can be stronger than
one female but no male is stronger than
five females so I think that this is
just a really important lesson from
bonobos that we can learn
and and and why did you have something
to edit I love her lover I try to say
good friends with all her her
girlfriends yes no good bonobo Bruno
Burgas all the chimps have this
reputation of being these kind of these
fighting aggressive primates and the
bonobos as you're describing have this
have the opposite reputation and why is
that I mean is there any sense as to why
the bonobos have or is that even true
yes no it is absolutely true and I think
I should just say that I am NOT a
chimpanzee racist
I actually know that there are lots of
like wonderful wonderful things about
chimpanzees and you know they are they
have emotions like love if you believe
the recent news reports they want it
dead so there is this really wonderful
side of them just like there is this
wonderful side to humans but yes there
is also this darker side and that's you
know something we have in common with
them so bonobos are really I think they
they have an important lesson for us and
it's not that I am saying that we should
be more like bonobos because they have a
lot of sex with everyone and I know
that's not you know I mean you know this
is if you're looking it's not something
I'm suggesting so but III think that you
know we can definitely look at the Novo
society and we need to learn more about
them because we don't know much about
them at all and so really figuring out
what it is about them that allows them
to live in a society with very little
violence is something very important for
us to study okay so I'm we work at a
beautiful sanctuary called Lola a bonobo
and Congo actually class works there too
and so they live the bonobos live in
this beautiful forest and they come into
a building at night where you know you
saw the previous experiment and so in
the daytime they live in these hundred
acres of forest just outside the capital
city of Kinshasa in Congo and last year
they had the world's first but no barrel
East but I just wanted to show you a
video of how beautiful it is and to see
if you can get an appreciation for
really what wonderful animals there are
and I know you do I'm so happy that you
all know about
it's really wonderful so can we roll the
next video please so this is them in the
morning and Pronovias spend a lot of
time in the water and jane goodall
recently came to visit lola and she was
just so stunned with you know how much
time they spend in the water cuz she
said she don't even seem that once or
twice and chimpanzees so baby bonobos
are absolutely king they're practically
like i said they were female dominant
but i think they're actually baby
dominated you can see these little baby
you can just get away with anything so
there's always a random frog so they're
incredibly playful creatures and and
actually you know one of the main
mechanisms is sex but also bonobos play
a lot and this kind of you know also
helps to keep the society in Congo
yes Brian can I add something
yes go ahead I had to ask permission um
so one of the other things that we found
by comparing how bonobos and chimps
develop is it ends up that bonobos
really are sort of like the Peter Pan
ape in our family and one of the new
ideas exhibited here of why bonobos
might be so peaceful and able to get
along is if they're really they never
grow up
they're they're a bit these pallets by
the way this is the Casa de there they
seem to be a bit juvenile lies in their
behavior and so if you look at chimp
juveniles and bonobo juveniles they're
actually very similar but what happens
is when chimps go through puberty they
really change whereas bonobos don't they
sort of stay in the same way as they
were when they were younger so you know
maybe we can just be a little bit more
juvenile and be better off
all right so let's let's change the
focus for a second so altruism sharing
affiliative social groups we can cross
old all that off the list of our list of
our own specialness now klaus turning to
you you know one of the ways that we
think of as human beings as I mentioned
before our special is that we use these
words we make sentences we have grammar
we have meaning we talk to each other we
talk to each other now you you study
something that might be called language
but it's not in humans it's in monkeys
and you you you study it in the forest
and the ivory coast am i right
that's right so can you set up you the
first time you went there because you've
been doing this for a long time the
first time you went there why did you go
what were you thinking and what were you
listening for well basically I just
wanted to get out of Switzerland chance
to do research in the ivory coast you
know for a master's degree at the time
and I thought it's great and so yeah
there I was in this forest and it's you
know I mean everyone has this idea of a
jungle being you know something romantic
and wonderful no but it's it's quite the
opposite it's it's it's dark it's moist
and you know everything bottle suder's
in insects flying around and and you
don't see the animals because they're
high up in the trees and can you hear
them you can hear them well yes and
that's the way to locate them usually
you just start to recognize the
different sounds and and that's how I
find the monkeys and then it took us
about half a year to habituate the first
grow you know so that they wouldn't run
away from us the whole time no what does
that mean you you you sit now these are
monkeys that live yeah right so there
are 20 30 meters up in the trees and you
sit underneath them until the gate
that's with you that's the only only way
you can you can do that because there's
a lot of poaching going on in many
parts of Africa and so naturally the
monkeys are very scared of humans and
with time they get used to you and just
start to ignore you essentially and and
that's when you can really start doing a
proper research and as you said when we
were particularly interested in in their
communication their their vocal did you
have an idea when you went to the forest
the first time that actually they could
maybe be talking to each other like
actually using words yeah there was
there was previous research that was
done in the savanna on on burbot monkeys
and that was stuff going in the
seventies eighties and and we knew
already that the burbot monkeys had
different alarm calls for different
predators so for instance if if a
Berbick monkey saw an eagle flying by
would give a particular alarm call and
and others would know just from hearing
the call that an eagle was nearby but
that was one x one example but there are
200 something species of primates and we
just didn't know if that was a general
feature of primate cognition and
communication or not and that's really
where this whole research began that we
wanted to know from other species if we
would find the same types of patterns or
not and so I started with the Diana
monkeys and and it turned out that in
fact they do have the same system
different alarm calls for what is the
data to see what kind of monkey is the
Dian monkey Dino it's you know it's one
of these colorful forest guenons and
they live in in groups with Otto such as
the Campins monkey so that's one
interesting thing in this African
forests that sometimes you've got four
or five six species of monkeys that form
one group together and the reason they
do that presumably is because they it
protects a much better against predation
so if it's basically a you know more
eyes that pay attention and what we
found very quickly is that each species
has their own alarm call system and and
they understand each other
so in the first video clip if you could
play that please are you gonna see a
campus monkey giving an alarm called
Sirius here's examples monkey so that's
the the leopard alarm called then the
monkey give sight to Dian among the
years this particular Cole then he would
first of all with his own leopard alarm
called that you're acoustically
different but also do stuff that you do
an electric surrounds you you know look
on the ground and try and locate the
thing and perhaps perhaps start mopping
if they concede and so on so they they
have an understanding of what the of
what this stuff means so if if a Diana
monkey sees a leopard below it makes
that sound all the other Diana monkeys
like oh my god Leopard and they what
Iran they well we that's what we thought
they might do but in fact in in the
forest the best strategy for monkey is
to to stay with the leopard at the safe
distance and just call and call and call
because leopards really depend on ambush
they can't hunt successfully if they're
being detected so for a monkey the best
thing to do is just a signal to the
leopard that it's been detecting it's
really pointless to hang around and we
with with radio tracked leopards and in
fact we you know that's what happens as
soon as the monkey seed that the light
port some were hiding in the bush and
they stalk alarm calling the leopard
slowly gets or just wanders off to the
leopard knows the leopard alarm claw as
well as the monkeys well I mean the
thing may be but certainly what they
know is that they've been detected and
it's just not gonna work they know
they're never going to catch one and so
so that's you know a strategy that's
very different from what they do in the
more open savanna habitat or they run
away as you see now in the next video is
an auto species the potty knows bunk you
know this one we've looked at in Nigeria
and they also have leopard and eagle arm
calls if you could play the next video
gonna say that's a legal alarm as a male
that has just seen an eagle my gift is
hack the sequences and and they also
have a leopard alarm code which is
acoustically different just like the
campus monkey but in addition what we
found in this species is that sometimes
they combine these two called so there
is a PR which is normally given to
leopards and then followed by a few
hacks which is normally given to eagle
now if they do that this combination and
it means something entirely different
then a Labrador an eagle it means let's
go away let's move and only the adult
males do that and sometimes when they
think it's it's spooky or it's not quite
right and they want the group to move
then they produce this combination of
calls and then usually the whole group
sort of wanders away and the next video
you're going to see such a PR hack
combination so first is a piano and then
followed by a few hacks if you listen
carefully you can you can probably hear
it
next video please
who hacks right and so that doesn't mean
left burning it doesn't mean ego but it
means let's go let's go so they have a
word would you call it a word actually
if I if I use that loosely they so they
have a word for leopard yeah which is
the danger from below we have a word for
Eagle which is danger from above but
they put the two together it doesn't
mean leopard and eagle it means though
yeah let's go something else I think
word is perhaps not the right thing
because I mean you know that the key
feature of our words obviously is that
it's learned you know we it's an
arbitrary utterance that has no sort of
deeper biological grounding and I mean
these calls they they just develop I
mean there's nothing there's no learning
in that sense I mean I think the the
meaning is learned for them they have to
listeners have to learn what what the
stuff means but the production is pretty
hardwired we do see any instances in the
forest of creatures learning one
another's calls yeah that's very very
common and not just so all the monkeys
understand each other for instance but
then we also found oddly that some birds
understand monkey alarm calls there's
there's various these large horn builds
that you find in African forests and so
we we've done some playback experience
and so for example if you play a lap a
monkey leopard alarm
called to a home build and the hornbill
just pretty much ignores it because they
live high up in the canopy and leopards
just aren't really relevant to them but
you play a monkey Eagle alarm called and
they get very excited and give their own
alarm calls and start look flying around
looking for the Eagle and so on so even
birds understand monkey talk
Wow now so in the next video we're going
to see a third monkey species that
looked black and white colobus monkey or
Gary so they're a little different they
only have one basic call type a deep
roar which you're gonna hear in a second
and they don't just give single roast
but they give sequences of roars and the
other thing here is that the the meaning
is not so they also you know they're
worried about leopards and the Eagles
the same story again but what they do is
if they if they see a lapper to give
sequences of just a few rows like two or
three let me take a break and then
there's another two or three or or
sequence and so on if they see an eagle
then it's usually much longer sequences
consisting of seven eight roars but it's
the same basic call type it's just
assembled in it in a different way and
that you know we thought was quite
unique so we thought well you know is it
really the case that they understand
that I mean do they pay attention to
this sequential organization of calls
and for that we we did a playback
experiment so we recorded an eagle
sequence and played it you know from a
speaker or we we played a leopard
sequence and what you expect of course
is if you play in the leopard sequence
that they start looking on the ground
and if you play man eagle sequence this
search the sky all right that's where
the predator comes from I'm going to
show two video clips in the first one I
believe it's the long sequence so what
your predictor is that the monkey would
start looking upwards and in the second
one it's the lab bird sequence and then
he should look down and so if you if we
could play the next video
in the background that's our playback is
this roaring thing and you know the
monkey looked upwards now in the next
video you're gonna hear the leopard
roaring again that's our playback that
you hear and you can you can watch other
monkey responds can I ask you a quick
question you say our playback or what do
you have like a boom box pointed at the
trees or something yeah you could you
could I mean you want that the point is
you need equipment reproduces it sounds
extremely faithfully I mean if you you
know if you have poor if you have a boom
box maybe the quality isn't so good
there discerning there is a very
specialist equipment that that has just
a very very good frequency response and
then you know you know you're not gonna
you know have a problem that way so we
position to speak or somewhere in the
vicinity of the monkey so that of course
it can't see that would be wrong and
then and then you know when the monkey
is unaware we play it and then we
recheck the response in the next video I
think that's the response to the lab for
flaws
I say single Ross in this case and
clearly the guy was sleeping he wasn't
really a very interesting and then he
hears that and then he doesn't look up
but he look he looks down so that's in a
sense the kind of proof that we can
deliver to demonstrate these things I
want to say very quickly a few things
about Apes because if we're interested
in language evolution we really want to
have evidence from apes and so we did a
study in Edinburgh Zoo with the
chimpanzees and the chimpanzees they
when they find food they produce a rough
grunt that's their food call and and
what we thought what we had a suspicion
that the rough grounds were acoustically
a little bit great it wasn't always the
same rough ground we gonna hear it in a
second we're going to hear a rough grant
given by etching this chimp has just
found some food announces that by
producing these signals and that's of
course interesting Paul the obviously
you know otters will then sort of show
up and see what's going on and so on and
but the call is not always the same
sometimes it sounds like that sometimes
it sounds a little different and so we
we first gave him different foods you
know we gave him stuff that they like
such as bread you know in the zoo oddly
enough and stuff they don't like such as
apples and when we recorded the calls
and looked at you know the acoustic
difference in sure enough if you know
the bread calls were different from the
Apple calls and to check if that was
meaningful to them we establish two two
food trees bread tree and an apple tree
and they so the team's learned very
quickly that on the one side they can
always find bread and then the other
sort of apples and so on that wasn't
very hard for them and then in the in
the key condition we played back from a
speaker either Apple calls or Brett
calls and then checked were they
forged more and it turned out that if
they hurt the bread cost and they would
look more underneath the bread treat and
underneath the apple tree and vice versa
so he was it was meaningful to them so
in the next video you're gonna hear the
the bread call I think so did the
previous almost the Apple call now this
is the bread call they can use it
slightly more tonal and it's the same
animal it's the same guy right but a
little acoustic difference and that's
you know others can understand that so
there's meaning encoded in this in this
very simple signal now in the final
study on briefly introduced we're going
to look at something else not meaning
but what we sometimes call
intentionality you know when we speak to
one another we don't just sort of talk
but we have some I want to talk to
someone we haven't you know we have a
message we want to share knowledge with
someone and and to do that you know we
have to find common ground and and be
sure that the other understands and so
on we do and so the origins of this
behavior you can see sometimes in some
social calls that a monkey's lips do and
in the next video you're gonna see a
bonobo who wants as a male and we you
know we know already how wimpy this
particular male you can see just by the
size difference you know he's he's very
keen to play with his female and he
wants to be chased by her and for that
he has to work quite hard he can't just
walk up and make her do it he has to
convince her and he uses vocalizations
to do that and it's and in the end he
succeeds so see what how he does it so
he could play the video so here he walks
up now he peeps
the alter distressed for those not just
vocalizations it's a combination that's
amazing it's a whole drama that unfolds
right there I mean you feel like they're
having a conversation well I think
they're you know I think he's just
trying to influence her I think a
conversation I think is probably a
little too much for that
but definitely I mean there's definitely
an intention to alter her behavior and
do something together you know it's
about the joint activity in this case
and he uses these vocal signals to
achieve that so that I think is to me oh
yeah all right so let's talk about big
brains for a second I said earlier
somewhat knowingly that that it is our
big brains that separate us and and
Jeremy you have you have said that
people should be asking not why do
insects which is your specialty not why
they have small brains but why do we
have big brains why do we have such big
brains what do you mean by that
yeah I think I mean in contrast to the
rest of the panel I don't work on
anything that's there's big ol cuddly I
feel quite sorry for myself but but one
of the things that that my research
tries to emphasize is that insects
really can do the most amazing things
with very very tiny brains and when you
when you can see how much sophistication
they have it kind of makes you wonder
why you need an extra billion neurons or
so - - and a huge brain to be able to do
something that a human does so if we can
have a look at the first slide this
might give you an idea of how big or
small
insect brains are so what you can see on
there are some animals you might be more
familiar with there isn't a bonobo I
don't think there is a man on there
right at the top and a whale and then
further down though the red points
that's one of them's a locust one of
them's a bee and one of them is an end
and you can see that they're actually
tiny in comparison I mean we're talking
about animals that have a brain the size
of a pinhead and yet bees can they have
language they can they can do something
called a waggle dance to tell one
another about where where they should go
and forage and they can do teaching they
can do something called tandem running
which which conforms to all the things
that we think of as teaching so really
the the behavioral sophistication of
insects is amazing perhaps we can look
at the next slide and you can see a bit
more of what an insect brain looks like
this is a this is a kind of diagram of a
bee and we've cut it away so you can see
the brain lying directly underneath the
head capsule there and what you can see
is that is the big compound eye and the
green regions of the other visual
regions of the bee brain and then you
can see these big blue structures at the
tops they're called the mushroom bodies
because they look a bit like mushrooms
and they're actually where the bees do
learning and memory and bees can do all
kinds of incredible learning and memory
tasks and then down at the bottom that
there are those those little dots the
circular structure - the dots they're
actually the antennae lobes where the
bees do all fashion however that's how
they smell so what we read in turn is is
kind of seeing how these brains these
tiny tiny brains can do really
sophisticated behavior and just to give
you a bit more of an idea of what a
brain in and set looks like we're going
to have a look in the next next video of
locust brain and so if we could play the
next video please
here we go so this isn't a fluorescence
microscope and what we're going to see
you're seeing we're moving through the
brain of the locust so if we see that
again you start off with the antennae
lobes and mushroom bodies and then
through in these big struck that big
structure at the end is one of the lobes
of the brain that processes visual
information it sits under the
and of the compound I and all those
connections all those that there's about
a million neurons in that brain and
they're they're able to do the most
incredible things so one of the things
that we found very recently is that
locust can actually use their vision to
control their legs while they're walking
but that that might sound like a kind of
trivial thing if you're a human or maybe
if you study bonobos or chimps but but
really using information from the world
that you get from your visual system to
inform you about where to place your
legs while you're walking or your arms
when you're reaching for something
is a really incredibly difficult thing
to do so if we can have a look at the
next video this might show you give you
an idea of what we've been doing with
the locusts so we get the locusts to
walk along a horizontal ladder and the
locusts have to place their rock their
feet on each subsequent rung of the
ladder and we filmed them in high speed
because they walk so quickly you if we
were if we were at normal speed you
wouldn't be able to see the legs moving
what is that what does that ladder
that's actually a ladder that's made out
of cocktail sticks it's expensive
research but the camera was a bit more
expensive than the computer and so the
the locusts are using vision here to
place their legs on each subsequent rung
of the ladder and that was a that was a
first for insect and that we didn't
think that they could do that before we
we saw this and what we do is we change
the spacing of the rungs so they can't
learn their spacing and we even make
rungs move while they're on the while
they're on the ladder and we can see
that there are some differences between
the way that the locusts tease their
vision and the way that humans do for
instance we if we're if we stumble
during us that we can update our
information we can place our leg in a
different position during the step but
the locust can't what they do is they
commit to the step and if the rung moves
out the way because some terrible
researcher has moved it they just fall
over
being being locust actually it doesn't
really hurt them very much they're
they're very light and they they don't
they don't get damaged now we've also
been quite interested in how insects
make decisions so what we're going to
see in the next video actually is is
something that I call a bush cricket but
which most of you probably call a
katydid and the if we can play the next
video what you're going to see is a
katydid it's walking along a wooden rod
and there's a gap and at the bottom of
the screen there's another wooden rod at
right angles to it and it's got to jump
across the gap and you can see it from
two different viewpoints now the tricky
thing for the inside here is that it has
to judge the distance of the gap very
very accurately if it gets it wrong it
will just fall and so what it does is it
uses its it's vision and it also uses
its antenna which at the front of the
head you can see them moving to judge
the distance of the gap and decide what
the best strategy is now if you always
jump that's a bit of a problem if the
gaps very short you might just jump
straight across it and so what we've
actually done is changed the size of the
gap and if we can see in the next videos
so if we could if we could stop that and
play the next video okay there's the
bush cricket jumping across the jumping
across the gap that's quite a big gap um
but if we now go to the next video what
you should be able to see is a much
smaller gap and here it doesn't jump at
all it actually makes the right decision
it reaches across the gap and keeps on
walking to the other side so you can see
that they can actually adjust what their
behavior depending on the size of the
gap Jimmy let me ask you uh why why why
making a locust walk across a ladder
practice and why not why measure the
jump of a why um that's a very good
question
I guess I guess for me the answer is
that that if we're talking about an
animal I said that insects had very
small brains relatively to something
like a bonobo chimp we might be able to
get an idea of what the neurons and then
and the neural circuits are in the brain
that actually produced these behaviors
and so for us the finding the behavior
is exciting but what's more exciting is
actually finding the neurons that
produce the behavior in the first place
and these these tasks that we get the
insects to do a way of us kind of
pushing the boundaries of what we think
insects are capable of but then we can
go back in and and say okay but what
neurons are actually controlling this
now how can we get these sophisticated
behaviors what you're actually we've got
another video and this one is a learning
task so we often associate intelligence
with learning which is perhaps not not
necessarily fair I don't know what the
others think of that but um one of the
things that we can get we can get the
locusts to do is we can get them to
learn and odor means food so what we do
is we put it we put a locust into it
into a what we call a why maze so it's
just a little little tunnel with two two
different tunnels coming off it and they
have to decide which arm of the Y maze
to walk down and beforehand when they're
completely untrained they go towards
vanilla and away from lemon probably
many of you do the same thing but let
the lemons kind of bitter the vanilla
probably smells quite nice to them and
what we do is we then say okay we want
to make sure they go to lemon and we'll
do that by telling them that lemon means
food so we have a little diet for the
locusts and we feed them and we at the
same time we give a lemon odor and then
after they've been trained the locusts
will will learn that lemon is good and
they'll remember this R up to 24 hours
afterwards and so we can see a locust
that's been trained in the next video so
he played the neck
video now so here's the focus being
released into the wine maze
and here it goes
and it's going to reach the decision
point any moment there we go
which way is lemon which ways Manila
it's right lemon is right so so the
locust should and vanillas left there we
go then I wouldn't have shown you a
locust that made the wrong decision and
you can see that little blue hole is
where the lemon odors come in from so
the locust walks right the way up to it
hmm
so so really you can see that that
insects despite being very small and not
cuddly at all do do a lot of incredible
behaviors and they even they can even
live in large groups and honeybees can
form colonies and they have female
dominated societies and you know the
repertoire that they have is really
quite incredible I mean there are some
downsides to group living in insects if
you're a locust and you live in a swarm
if you stay still for too long you might
get eaten by one of your fellow locusts
and they go in for cannibalism in quite
a big way but apart from that that
they're there they're really nice
animals and one of my colleagues has
actually taken taken this a bit further
and actually kind of asked whether
insects have an aesthetic sense so he
worked with an artist for a little while
and he actually tested whether bees
prefer different types of paintings it's
not really science but it's it's it's
interesting nonetheless and we have a
video of that now to show you those
a colony of bees bred in captivity
they've never seen a real flower or a
work of art but they're taking part in a
unique experiment to test their artistic
taste but released into a specially
designed flying gallery and the bees
movements monitored to see which
paintings they like most the selection
of the world's best art was on offer
bangor famous sunflowers a classic from
go gasps then in contrast other colorful
works but with no flowers in sight the
experiment showed the bees had strong
views on what they preferred we found
very interestingly that bees came and
they looked most at the van Gogh
sunflowers and actually landed on these
flowers and they clearly recognized them
as as flowers whereas the more abstract
paintings that had lots of colors in
they were less interested in wait a
second there's nothing to do with art
that's just a flower it's look what's
going to the flowers yes I might have
chosen some different painting but
before we go to powder you did it did
they have a preference between van Gogh
and Gauguin I think they did I think
they preferred Franco yeah really oh
they they like the summer yeah okay I
think it's the high contrast this you
know this the Brown Center and the
yellow petals around it well all right
so our final our final panelist Patrick
Hoff can you tell it so emotion is one
of the things that I'd mention at the
top that we as human beings have a very
rich ability to exchange emotions and to
empathize with one another
is there any how should we say neural
evidence that other creatures can share
this ability with us or can do it with
us yes actually we tend to we tend
always to think that we are we are
unique and in many of the function
behaviors that we display and and I
think there has been ample evidence from
the panel that this is indeed not the
case but there is certainly much to
learn from other species so - to put
things a little bit in context we my
group is is for mostly of neuroanatomist
we study the brain but we study the
brain post-mortem and so we know
everything but one day too late and and
we do this not only in in the human but
also in a large variety of mammals and
we try to do some comparison about the
structure of the brain because you know
like Francis Crick said if you want to
learn about function you have to study
the structure and that's really true we
cannot learn anything about the function
of an organ without knowing the cellular
components and the brain is is
extraordinarily complicated even the
brain of a bee is extraordinarily
complicated so the brain of a human is
quite something and in addition in human
you have an enormous amount of diversity
of into inter inter individual diversity
that complicates everything and then
among mammals you have many many many
species so that to puts a layer of
complexity about what we can retrieve
from the structure and then what is
absolutely fascinating is that you can
find elements in there that occurs in
different group of animals and means
something that is fundamentally
fundamentally important and teaches us
about these functions that we try to
understand better so in order to do all
that I to add to get out of Switzerland
so you will you will recognize speaking
about language some subtle difference
in accent between Klaus and me he comes
from the German part and I come from the
french-speaking part you know sweet zone
is great we boast falling wages and and
thousands of little local dialect so
that the guy who is here cannot
understand the guy we are great
communicators and citizens so and one of
the reason why I got out of Switzerland
was to study certain species of animals
for which there was little opportunity
in Switzerland like if you play the
video like this you cannot find them
find that social manner they are playful
they are communicating they know each
other they know themselves they can
recognize other members of a group they
are absolutely amazing they do a lot of
things that we do so what of the the
determinants of the of such behavior
well we started from the human brain and
we stumbled one day on a very strange
type of neurons in the human brain
that's that cell that is that is very
thin and elongated like a spindle and we
call them spindle cells why what is the
spindle binoy it's it's like the
fusiform shape neurons so if you would
take the surface of the brain here and
the bottom of cerebral cortex here that
cell would be located like this and
again that is that is a very unusual
structure for a neuron most neurons look
like triangles or like little over in
structures but not like a big giant
spindle like this
we renamed these neurons phone Economo
cells because they have been described
for the first time by Constantine phone
Economo who was a neuroanatomist of the
1920s and he said you know in the
anterior cingulate cortex and the
frontal insular cortex there are these
weird things and he had some ideas about
what they would do and then these cells
fell in oblivion for many years until we
rediscovered them so we were very
excited because we had found a new cell
in the human brain and for three days we
thought we had hit glory here so no
anatomies to find a new cell in the
brain it's quite something and and and
after three days we looked at the old
literature and of course we saw that one
of the old guy had been there before us
that's okay question is we have a neuron
I'm gonna show you other examples of
these morphologies you know here you
ever you have a spindle cell that is
just next to a classical pyramidal cell
you can see the differences in size and
the difference in morphology of these
neurons so what do we sell do and why
would this cell type be located only in
a particular layer of the serval cortex
in only two regions of the cerebral
cortex so what are these regions the
anterior cingulate cortex and the
frontal insular cortex regions that we
know from functional brain imaging in
humans to be involved in a variety of
behaviors and functions that are again
is extraordinarily human type of
behavior such as social awareness
empathy theory of mine you know the type
of things like I can I can think I can
see that Jan there is doing pretty fine
right now and that is probably thinking
why is that I single me out now
so that I that type of capacity but
judgment morality emotion regulation all
of these very high order cortical
processing functions that we think are
profoundly associated with with our
brain so they are in these regions and
in a quite fascinating manner it was
found by colleague of Mines gentleman at
Caltech and the william sealy at UCSF
that in some particular case of dementia
these neurons are specifically and
dramatically affected now these people
with type of dementia are known as from
Thoth and Perl dementia lose completely
their social awareness they have a blunt
affect they have no empathy they have no
theory of mind and they have a loss of
these neurons ah that's interesting
these neurons might be at the basis of
this particular Network that's observe
these functions now our next step was
okay this is great we have a human a
human the run let's look in the macaque
monkey why because the macaque monkey is
an animal that is used in research and
is used in neuroscience a lot as as a
model for him we can do a lot with
macaque monkey we can study them we can
study them for their behavior we can
elicit response from them and so on and
we found nothing macaque monkeys do not
have spindle cells in their brain
so the next logical step of course was
to look at the brain of the chimpanzee
and bingo chimpanzees do have spindle
cells they're our closest relative the
bonobos we are not forgetting the
bonobos bonobos have plenty and in fact
the bonobo is the species in which the
distribution of spindle cells mimic the
closest that in the human surprise
surprise
except maybe for the woman dominated and
we found them of course in gorillas and
orangutans and so just to put things in
context there this is a human brain this
now is a chimpanzee brain so is it's a
slightly smaller brain but lots of
convolution lots of complexity in there
here is a species here is a species that
doesn't have its Bendall so that's the
brain of a Gibbon so the lesser he
doesn't have been all cells so it's
really something that occurred in the
hominids and at this point we were very
happy right because that was no hominid
specific neuron so we could actually
date it
that's a neuron that was 16 million
years old it's a recent thing in
evolution and it's only among us then of
course I had the - curiosity to look in
other species you've seen that I like
whales and this is the brain of the fin
whale so that's big okay that's the
brain that is about that big so that
poses other technical complexities and
of course in that species we found
plenty of spindle cells
this is the tail of a fin whale
well it's diving here is a blue whale
just taking a breath you are here
another blue whale this isn't the Saint
Laurent story so you see these animals
are quite complicated to study you know
they are elusive you have to be in the
sea and you don't see for much time so
you have to track them it's difficult
these are two fin whales and swimming
socially this is the brain of a sperm
whale another big brain we find them in
the sperm whale so the fin whale is a
misty seed it's a balun whale the sperm
whale is a completely different type of
animal it's 2/3 whale it's a way of that
echolocate this is a much smaller animal
that's the Beluga the white whale and
that's a smaller animal extremely social
animal they from group of several
hundreds and they have very many very
many of these of these Pindell neurons
as well and here is the brain of a
species of dolphin that does not spin
that's the Amazon River dolphin inia and
these are again completely different
animals they have had a completely
different evolutionary story they are
adapted to a completely different
ecological niche and interestingly they
are smaller bodied and they have a
smaller brain so it has to do with some
with being a large animal with a big
brain within an order Patrick if you
were to tell a story about all of the
creatures that you have found do have
spindle cells versus the creatures that
don't what would you say how would you
tell that story would you say these are
the creatures that do a
B&C or don't do alien sea at this point
yes these are these are we find these
these cells also in the in the elephant
and the story almost ends here
so elephant large situation large
primates and these are all the species
that have a very active social life that
ever sense of self-awareness they can
recognize themselves in the mirror they
can recognize individual and say okay
this is X this is y this is Z they in
many cases probably have a sense of
empathy certainly it's been documented
in a in elephant they are loved loved
animals they all reproduce relatively
slowly and they all have a sense of
capacity for communication so that is a
set of very particular very particular
capabilities in among these animals now
there is something interesting here this
is the brain of a hippopotamus
so the hippopotamus if you look at the
phylogeny is the closest relative to
cetaceans okay cetaceans become became
completely adapted to an aquatic meal
but they came from terrestrial or before
something that looked like probably a
furry hippopotamus some you know 50
million years ago so guess what they all
spindle cells in the brain of the
hippopotamus but there is a problem is
that in the hippopotamus you find these
neurons all over all the cerebral cortex
they are not localized only in the
cingulate cortex and the frontal insular
cortex they are everywhere which means
that this may be the ancestral state and
in these other species these cells the
the network that these cells the cells
form has been progressively refined
as a measure of adaptive pressure
in which this to which the species were
exposed and I think I'm gonna leave you
with these ideas and a beautiful picture
of Athena whales swimming in the Saint
long well well Thank You Patrick
thank you everyone but we did promise
that we would have actual creatures
become a part of this panel so I guess
this is my chance just to hand it over
to you and can we get the can we get our
six through nine panelists back out here
actually what we're gonna do is we're
gonna bring it out one at a towel we're
gonna ring it okay yeah so so hang on
and let me just give some background to
what we're gonna what we're going to see
here and I feel like I'm Jack Bauer I
have a clock up here they're speaking
you guys can't see it because I have a
theory of mind and what a theory of mind
is it means I can think about what
you're thinking about and I know what's
in your mind potentially so I know you
can't see this clock and I know that I
can so we use this ability to think
about what others are thinking about all
the time when we're making social
decisions and it's something that people
think is crucial to what makes us human
so developmental psychologists have done
a beautiful job at studying how the
ability to think about other individuals
thinking how that develops and it ends
up you're not born with this ability and
by the time and anybody who has had a
four a three-year-old and then a four
year old will be very aware that by the
time your kid is 4 they're very skilled
at deceiving you and very actively and a
three-year-old can do it too but
probably not quite as skillfully and the
reason is because there's a major shift
in how people think about the thoughts
of others ok so because we're interested
in what makes us unique and how our
unique skills develop people wanted to
know is it that animals not only do they
think because actually most scientists
would easily agree absolutely animals
think they make decisions in their life
all the time but the but the even more
complex and interesting question is do
they know that others are thinking can
they actually assess what somebody else
knows and doesn't know
so one of the ways that we do this as
humor
and one of the ways that small children
just start to think about the thoughts
of others is that they they you they
start to pay attention to social cues
okay so I look up and you see me look up
and you instantly say the guy's nuts or
he saw something but the point is you
all were thinking about what I was
thinking about okay
and the first way we do this is we start
paying attention to social cues like
this so people got fascinated by the
question is this capability also in
animals okay so as a student with my
advisers an undergraduate I went out and
started playing games with chimpanzees
and it was a very simple game in the
same game that we play with young
children to assess their ability to
think about the thoughts of others and
it ends up that chimpanzees weren't very
good at the game so if you hide food in
one of two places and the chimpanzee
knows that food is hidden in the case of
young children it'll be a small toy and
you try to just tell the chimpanzee
where the where the food is by either
pointing or looking or standing close to
where the food is well they can't figure
it out they have no clue where the thing
is that's been hidden and so so young
children are very good at this and it's
one of the first things that comes
online when you're between 18 and 24
months old so that seemed to be
beautiful evidence that this is
something crucially important not only
to be human but to develop human
language and human culture and so this
was a big idea that people were very
excited about I went to my advisor at
Emory when I was an undergraduate and I
said you know what I just did all these
tests for the chimps they're really
abysmal
even though chimpanzees as Klaus is
beautifully demonstrated they do
communicate they do gesture they do have
vocal communication but they're not able
to solve this very simple problem but I
you know I think my dog does that any
time everybody's dog does calculus you
know whatever you know go away but being
a fantastic advisor his name's Mike
Tomasello
being a fantastic advisor he said all
right fine you only
why don't you do an experiment so the
experiment I'm gonna do today with our
volunteers is the experiment that we did
with young children that we did with
chimpanzees and that we did with dogs
and the punchline is it ends up dogs are
incredibly good at this at using social
cues that young children use as they
begin to develop language and
participate in human culture and
chimpanzees really struggle with okay
now I'm taking a big risk to demonstrate
this with you guys today and our
volunteers are very brave to bring their
beautiful pooches that are like their
children here to try this game out I
can't tell you what's going to happen
because what I study is not learning
it's not you know this is not going to
be the the David Letterman Show where
you know we come out and have cute pet
tricks this is how real science happens
so you're gonna see at the duke canine
cognition Center at Duke University we
bring people in and we test their dogs
we don't give them any training we want
to see what the dog can do spontaneously
what does it understand about its world
what kind of inferences can it make now
the Duke canine cognition Center and all
the places where people have studied dog
cognition they don't have hundreds of
people watching okay
so I've actually never done this before
so it may be that the dogs struggle a
little bit but it doesn't matter because
they're wonderful because they're dogs
and I'm sure all of you are dog lovers
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
try Sammy first if Sam you can't come
out it'd be great and we're just gonna
have two hiding locations here on stage
let's give Sammy a Hannah round of
applause hey Sammy
all right so if Sammy can just sit
between where we got him all right now
I'm gonna show him some food now Sammy
is adorable get this I've already we did
I did show him that I was gonna hide
food here a little bit before the show
and he is wonderful check this out okay
stay there Sammy okay stay there how
cute is that all right now stay there
now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna hide
the food one or two places but I'm not
gonna show him where okay so even you
won't know where I've hidden it okay and
then what I got to do is I'm gonna say
Sammy all right better than a chimpanzee
fantastic okay good Brian can I ask a
question here are we sure Sammy's not
smelling the food well
okay great so who thinks he's smelling
the food raise your hand okay fantastic
so we do science we're not into religion
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
test our ideas empirically all right
Sammy now what I'm gonna do if you sit
down thank you you're so beautiful
is I'm gonna do the same thing but this
time I'm gonna do a control condition
and I'm not gonna give him a cue and
let's just see if he finds the food okay
Sammy so the cheese was here okay so I
didn't put cheese I didn't put cheese in
the other bucket and you see that when
he doesn't have a social cue he goes to
the wrong place okay cuz he doesn't know
what to do so it ends up what we found
by playing this game over and over with
lots of different dogs
Oh poor Sammy here we go there you go
you're awesome
okay thank you so much so what we what
we've done by playing so so what we've
done by playing this game with lots of
different dogs and lots of induct in
lots of different labs across the world
is we found that dogs are incredibly
good at this they don't use olfactory
cues or their nose to find the food they
would much prefer that you help them
that you tell them where the food is
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
bring out is Molly next door Isabella I
can't remember who's next whoever's next
it's Bella
okay here's wonderful Bella now in
general so so people have studied
everybody's fascinated by breed
differences and one thing you might be
surprised to know is science is actually
just discovered the dog now I know
that's really funny because they're all
in our houses and everybody loves dogs
but most people do what we've talked
about study primates and insects and all
these other things but dogs are somehow
tainted in the view of science until
about 10 years ago they're artificially
selected and you know their dogs and
whatever how could they be interesting
and so for the past 10 years people been
studying dogs and the reason that's the
reason that it's so exciting Bella that
Bella's here is because Bella is
actually from one of the breeds where
there has been a breed difference
demonstrated now believe it or not dogs
that have shorter noses a group of
Hungary found that if you compare the
performance of dogs with shorter noses
to dogs that have longer noses on this
very simple game they actually do better
and one of the arguments for why that is
is that if you're a long nosed dog you
have a much narrower range of view or
field of vision and if you have a
shorter nose actually if you look at the
morphology of the retina in these dogs
they look more like humans they have a
much wider range so they can see the
cues better or not so this it's up to
Bella to represent the short nose dogs
okay here we go all right all right
Bella she's ready she's ready okay all
right so we're gonna hide the food let's
see where it should do here darling all
right okay like a champ
Bella here you go sweetie here you go
she's a little short to get it out
herself okay so fantastic thank you
thank you Bella
thank you darling all right
okay so next I've got Molly coming out
Thank You Molly here she is wonderful
now one of the other studies that we've
done is we're actually trying to apply
some of the stuff we're learning about
dog cognition and what we've learned in
the last ten years because the truth is
most of what we're doing is we're trying
to understand how intelligence or
cognition differs between different
species how it develops and we're trying
to learn about humans it's a very
selfish motivation but she's already a
winner okay mint for television so so
Bella I'm sorry so what so what people
it's been a very selfish endeavor trying
to understand humans by studying dogs
and actually my own work has been
involved okay
I got to be quicker this is getting
boring so the short version is that what
we wanted to understand is if dogs are
actually using these social cues are
they thinking about what you're thinking
about is it that they know what's going
on inside your head we've done lots of
studies to try to get at that and now
we're trying to apply that knowledge and
one of the things that's been
demonstrated is dogs are not disobedient
because they're dumb dogs are not
disobedient because they can't learn
dogs are disobedient because they know
what they can get away with
and one of the ways that they can figure
that out is based on cues of what you're
able to see and what you're not able to
see so I'm gonna try this with Molly I
have no idea what's gonna happen
but my guess is what do you think Molly
I'm gonna try this let's see what
happens um actually you know what I'm
not even gonna use the bowl so this is a
very simple experiment that was done by
a group in Germany has been replicated
by several other people and all I'm
gonna do is I'm going to show Molly that
I have some food hey darlin you are so
wonderful come here here I'll give you
something before I start okay all right
I'll cheat for you okay now what I'm
gonna do thank you that's perfect Eric
all right so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna put the food on the ground you go
Bobby okay now now what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna say Molly no don't take the
food no okay we're gonna wait for a
little bit oh she's really good okay now
what we're gonna do
I'll give it to her there you go all
right so that's one test condition so
that's pretty standard right she was
very obedient now here's the key test
condition now she may still just stay
there because she's such a sweetie and
she's so well-behaved but don't worry we
have one more dog who might not behave
so so I'm gonna put the food I'm gonna
do the same thing No
thank you Eric thank you okay so we got
one more dog we're gonna do the same
test and see what happens okay Thank You
Molly
so what we do is we're actually what we
do is we have mini dogs and we can
assess whole groups of dogs and
generally in a study will test 40 or 50
dogs and when I'm telling you a dog does
or doesn't do something it's actually an
average of what the average dog does but
there are many dogs at different
individually and so let's see what good
old Georgie does here and what kind of
dog is Georgie very nice mountain died
hey go Georgie
here you go Georgie oh there you go all
right sit can you sit no he's like eat I
can eat hey good girl
Georgie's mom was very clear to tell me
that Georgie is a female it's all right
Georgie all right you ready
okay okay okay no Georgie no no I mean
we're in trouble people all right
so sometimes they just go we can try one
more dive all right Georgie come here
come here Georgie come here so you can
see when we're trying to understand the
psychology of dogs we just play fun
games with them not anything that we
wouldn't do with our own kids all right
stay here Georgie state not stay stay
you're beautiful I love you but stay all
right that's okay
thank you very much
baby Georgie you did a good thing
I just want you to know I just want you
to know that Georgie did not fail that
test because he got all the food I was
the failure but but as just a closing
point when we study dogs we bring them
in we play fun games with them and what
we're really interested in is not what
they what they learn in our tests we're
interested in the inferences they can
make about their world when people have
done that it ends up that they do make
really strong inference ha's and that
they flexibly can solve problems even on
a first trial or a second trial and it's
not that you have to teach them
everything
in fact dogs come into the world and
they have special abilities relative to
other animals to really interact and use
people to their advantage so that's
basically the the summary of what we
found when we're studying dog cognition
so thank you very much
that pretty much wraps it up for us I
want to thank our panelists Patrick Hoff
Jeremy Niven Vanessa woods Klaus Zuber
Muller and Brian hare and of course our
creatures that came in and there's more
cheese if anyone wants it thank you for
coming and